bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est Paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux on commence avec une annonce je
serai le 5 mai au dernier bar avant la
fin du monde pour une petite conférence
et une rencontre avec les abonnés un peu
comme ce que j'avais fait à Grenoble il
y a quelques mois de cela donc ce sera
le vendredi 5 mai à 17h à Paris au
dernier bar avant la fin du monde je
ferai une petite présentation sur le
carreau et puis évidemment on en
profitera pour discuter et boire des
canons à la fin de la conférence donc
n'oubliez pas le 5 0 5 à 5h c'est pas
c'est pas difficile à retenir c'est la
dernière étape avant 6 6 voilà le
dernier bar avant la fin du monde les
planètes s'alignent vous avez tout
compris donc venez nombreux le 5 mai à
17h au dernier bar avant la fin du monde
une rencontre organisée par fossil vous
plaît que je remercie énormément pour
avoir organisément venez nombreux on
fera une petite conférence sur le
carreau et on boira des coups
paléontologique maintenant l'actualité
pour ce mois de mars et ce début avril
2023 a été très très très très largement
dominé par cet article cet article paru
dans la très prestigieuse revue Science
avec des grands noms génériques vous
avez Robert rice David Evans Mark Wilton
évidemment vu que ça parle de Paléo
artistes on ne peut pas ne pas inclure
le Paléo artiste et paléontologue Marc
Witten donc cet article qui nous annonce
que les dinosaures théropodes selon eux
avaient des lèvres donc si vous n'êtes
pas familier avec le débat je vous le
présente je vous le présente très
rapidement certaines personnes pensent
que les dinosaures théropodes donc comme
ce tyrannosauridé présenté ici
donc ici T-Rex
avait non pas les dents apparentes comme
on peut le voir dans Jurassic Park le
tyrannosaure de Jurassic Park a l'aidant
apparentes de cette façon là mais avait
en fait les dents recouvertes de
d'écailles d'un genre de rideau
d'écailles et ils avaient aussi beaucoup
de gencives recouvrant les dents
exactement comme on le voit chez les
varans donc les varans les iguanes les
lézards les serpents ils ont tous un
petit rideau d'écailles qui recouvre la
bouche et qui cache les dents et donc on
voit pas leur sourire donc ça c'est ce
qu'on voit par exemple chez les
vélociraptor de Jurassic Park donc voilà
là ça c'est ça c'est tyrannosaure de
Jurassic Park ça c'est Velociraptor de
Jurassic Park vous voyez c'est un débat
qui est pas qui est qui est pas nouveau
c'est un débat qui a lieu depuis très
longtemps et déjà à l'époque de Jurassic
Park ils avaient pas tranché ils avaient
fait un dinosaure avec les dents
apparentes pour qu'il ressemble à un
monstre et un dinosaure avec des lèvres
pour qu'il ait l'air plus intelligent
donc ça c'est un débat qui est pas
nouveau mais c'est un débat qui concerne
essentiellement les Paléo artistes les
paléontologues ne s'intéressent pas
énormément à ce débat moi il y en a qui
s'y intéressent vous voyez il y a quand
même une belle liste de co-auteur ici
mais les paléontologues les chercheurs
ne s'intéressent pas spécialement à ce
débat parce que c'est un débat qui n'a
aucune solution pour l'instant la seule
et unique preuve qui permettrait de
décider si ça c'est la vraie condition
ou bien ça donc pas de lèvres ou lèvres
ce serait de trouver un tyrannosaure
momifié ou un n'importe quel autre
théropode complètement momifié et
fossilisé qui préserve la région de la
gueule où on verrait si oui ou non les
lèvres couvraient les dents c'est pas
impossible ils ont des momies ils ont
des momies fossilisés en Amérique du
Nord les edmontosaure par exemple il y
en a il y en a quelques-uns il y a
Leonardo par exemple qui est très connu
donc il y a des momies de dinosaures
fossilisés en Amérique du Nord et donc
un jour peut-être qu'on sera chanceux
suffisamment chanceux pour trouver ça
mais pour l'instant ça n'est pas arrivé
la preuve
ultime qui permettrait de démontrer si
oui ou non il y avait des lèvres chez
les théropodes et ça je veux bien il
faut vraiment l'intégrer la preuve la
seule et unique preuve preuve dans le
sens le plus le plus profond du terme la
seule et unique preuve
de savoir si oui ou non il y avait des
lèvres ou pas chez les dinosaures
théropodes on ne l'a pas encore trouvé
il y a plein de dinosaures chinois qui
ont été retrouvés avec des tissus mous
il y en a aucun qui préserve cette
région là donc c'est pas les dinosaures
chinois qui vont nous aider donc pour
l'instant on ne sait pas et les
paléontologues ils ont pas besoin de
prendre cette décision savoir s'il y
avait des lèvres ou pas parce que
paléobiologiquement la présence de
lèvres c'est présence de lèvres ou non
ça change rien à la biologie du
tyrannosaure vous voyez le tyrannosaure
ça reste la même bestiole avec ou sans
lèvres par contre chez les
paléo-artistes c'est un débat qui fait
rage parce que il y a toujours un moment
chez les Paléo artistes où il va falloir
qu'ils prennent cette décision vous
voyez de savoir s'ils font leur
tyrannosaure comme si ou leur
tyrannosaure comme ça avec des lèvres ou
s'enlèvent donc c'est un débat qui est
très important pour les Paléo artistes
et en ce moment il y a un mouvement il y
a une mode ça va par mode c'est ça va
complètement par mode du pas c'est de ça
reste un milieu artistique donc les
modes sont très importantes au début si
vous regardez les représentations de
dinosaures de l'époque de Richard Owen
où on s'imaginait que les dinosaures
étaient juste des gros lézards et ben on
les représentait comme des gros lézards
or les lézards ils ont des lèvres et
puis petit à petit les dinosaures sont
devenus de moins en moins reptiliens et
de plus en plus arkozoriens alors les
arcoors ça reste des reptiles mais on se
comprend je veux dire sont de moins en
moins les ariformes et de plus en plus
crocodile il forme or les crocodiles eux
n'ont pas de lèvres donc au fur et à
mesure qu'on a représenté les dinosaures
de plus en plus crocodiliens et de moins
en moins lézard et ben on les a refait
avec moins de lèvres donc c'est Jurassic
Park avec les dents apparentes et donc
Jurassic Park étant le film le plus
populaire de son époque sur les
dinosaures il a lancé une grande mode de
représenter les dinosaures avec les
dents apparentes et puis maintenant
c'est le c'est l'époque ça y est de la
autre mode donc on en revient à une mode
où on veut remettre des lèvres à nos
dinosaures comme des bons vieux lézards
ce qui ne plaît pas à tout le monde
évidemment puisque bah une fois de plus
les dinosaures ne sont pas des lézards
les dinosaures sont des archosaures ils
sont plus apparentés aux crocodiles qui
n'ont pas de lèvres ils sont plus
apparentés aux oiseaux qui n'ont pas de
lèvres ça n'a rien à voir avec la
présence dedans ou pas bon bref vous
avez ce débat qui est en cours et donc
on est un peu en train de faire marche
arrière en ce moment niveau mode on va
dire on est en train de faire marche
arrière vers des dinosaures un petit peu
plus les ariformes donc des dinosaures
théropodes qui auraient des lèvres
exactement comme les varans de Komodo
comme les iguanes ou comme les ou comme
les serpents par exemple et qui
n'auraient donc pas les dents apparentes
contrairement à leurs cousins modernes
les crocodiles et les alligators donc ça
c'est le débat à l'heure actuelle à
l'heure actuelle on n'est pas capable de
trancher on a autant de bons arguments
pour que de bons arguments contre et
j'avais fait une vidéo pour résumer tous
ces arguments donc je vous la mets là là
vous voyez la vignette et vous pouvez
aller dans la description pour aller la
chercher si vous voulez avoir un résumé
du débat mais en gros c'est l'état du
débat actuel on n'est pas capable de
trancher à l'heure actuelle entre lèvres
ou pas lèvres il y a de très bons
arguments des deux côtés et de c'est
très bons arguments ne sont que des
arguments c'est à dire qu'ils sont
facilement contre argumentables la
preuve ultime je le répète ce serait de
trouver une momie d'un dinosaure
théropode avec la gueule préservée où on
verrait si oui ou non les dents étaient
couvertes c'est la seule preuve donc
vous pouvez d'ores et déjà
accepter l'idée que cet article
n'apporte pas cette preuve voilà que
qu'est-ce qu'il apporte cet article il
apporte de nouveaux arguments mais il
n'apporte pas cette preuve à aucun
moment dans cet article vous ne verrez
de de tyrannosaure momifié
voilà donc cet article n'apporte pas la
preuve qu'il y avait des lèvres ou non
chez les dinosaures théropodes ce que
fait cet article en l'occurrence c'est
rediscuter des arguments qui ont déjà
été mises sur la table
concernant le débat sur les lèvres donc
par exemple la position des petits
foramen au-dessus de la mâchoire donc
les petits foramen au dessus de la
mâchoire qui selon la façon dont vous
voulez regarder chez tyrannosaure sont
plutôt organisés façon reptile ou plutôt
organisée façon crocodile parce que
c'est un peu le problème c'est que cet
argument là en fait il a déjà été
discuté on n'arrive pas à pareil on
n'arrive pas à conclure là on a des
petits trous des petits foramen qui
normalement amènent des vaisseaux
sanguins et des nerfs dans les lèvres
chez les chez les varans chez les
iguanes etc etc ok on voit ça chez les
varans et les iguanes mais chez le
crocodile où on voit plein de petits
foramen sur le museau donc on pourrait
dire que la condition est différente
chez le crocodile qui lui n'a pas de
lèvres mais en réalité vous voyez la
rang foramen elle est là aussi chez le
crocodile il y en a aussi une rangée de
foramen qui suit là le la marge la marge
de l'os maxillaire et chez tyrannosaure
on a un peu la même condition que chez
le crocodile avec plein de petits forums
au dessus et une rangée de foramen qui
suit la marge dentaire donc on pourrait
tout aussi ici ils arguments que le
tyrannosaure ressemble plus au lézard et
au varan et au varan et aux iguanes mais
en réalité on pourrait aussi argumenter
que ça ressemble au crocodile et c'est
bien ça le problème ça a toujours été le
problème c'est pour ça que je dis cet
argument là il est pas nouveau ça a déjà
été fortement débattu pareil on n'arrive
pas à décider on n'arrive pas à décider
si oui ou non
ça ça veut dire quelque chose est-ce que
ça veut dire
ensuite il nous apporte l'argument de la
taille des dents donc c'est ce graphe là
argument de la taille des dents qui déjà
de base était pas très très costaud
c'est à dire que tyrannosaure aurait eu
des dents trop grosses pour que des
lèvres le recouvrent bon bon
donc c'était un argument contre qui
était facile à débanquer et puis bah là
il le débogue en disant que non le
tyrannosaure il a une taille dedans vous
voyez la taille dedans elle est à gauche
là en verticale et à l'horizontale ici
vous avez la taille du crâne donc la
taille des dents de tyrannosaure reste
relativement proportionnelle à la taille
de son crâne donc il y a pas donc s'il
avait des lèvres les lèvres n'auraient
qu'à être proportionnelle à la taille de
tout le reste donc au final on ne sait
pas un très bon argument et très
honnêtement vous m'auriez demandé je
vous aurais dit ouais bof
et donc le seul truc nouveau réellement
qu'apporte cet article
au débat c'est cette dent une seule et
unique dans quels ont coupé et dont ils
ont regardé la surface et ils ont dit eh
regardez ça c'est la surface de la dent
d'un
ça c'est dans la donc ça c'est la
surface de la dent d'un tyrannosauridé
d'un das splatosaurus et elle est nickel
alors que vous regardez la surface de la
dent d'un crocodile ici et ben elle est
vachement pétée et ça c'est parce que la
dent en fait elle était recouvert de
était recouverte de de tissus et de et
de salive et que du coup et bien elle
était protégée alors que chez les
crocodiles elle est pas protégée et du
coup elle les dents sont très abîmées à
cause de la dessication les mailles du
crocodile étant exposées à l'air libre
craque alors que celle de du
tyrannosauridé n'est pas craqué donc
elle ne devait pas être exposée à l'air
libre et ça ça pourrait ça c'est le
nouvel argument qui est mis sur la table
par cet article c'est la seule chose
nouvelle qu'apporte cet article au débat
et ça n'est qu'une seule dent d'un seul
tyrannosaure idée
c'est pas beaucoup c'est vraiment
vraiment pas grand chose quand on sait
qu'il y a des milliers dedans de
tyrannosauridés qui ont été retrouvées
et je déconne pas à chaque fois qu'ils
en à chaque fois qu'ils vont dans le
désert là dans le Dakota
ils en ont ils mettent des coups de pied
dedans quoi il y en a partout il y en a
partout des dents de tyrannosaures idées
donc il y en a des milliers
littéralement des dents de
tyrannosauridé on parle pas que de T-Rex
là on parle de d'aspectosaurus donc il y
en a des milliers et ils ont choisi de
Nantes de n'en étudier qu'une seule
alors je sais qu'il fallait couper
dedans et que ça fait mal au cœur de
couper dedans mais ça limite en fait la
possibilité de généraliser ses
conclusions quoi c'est ça le gros le
gros problème c'est pas pourquoi vous
avez été radin en bande de dinosaure
c'est la grande question c'est comment
est-ce qu'on généralise un résultat
aussi ponctuel quoi c'est juste un point
bon ok 7 dans là elle est nickel mais
combien combien vous avez laissé passer
dedans un peu pour rave pour trouver
cette dent nickel bah la question la
réponse vous l'aurez pas donc cet
article prouve-t-il démontre-t-il la
présence de lèvres chez tyrannosaure et
chez les autres théropodes comme cela a
été annoncé évidemment dans les médias
les bons médias oui les bons médias ont
démontrent la présence des lèvres chez
tyrannosaure bah non on ne démontre rien
du tout cet article tout au plus il
valide certains arguments qui avaient
déjà été non validés donc celui-là donc
bon ça se débat valide il valide enfin
il invalide l'argument des dents trop
longues pour dire qu'il y avait pas de
lèvres
admettons et il apporte sur la table ce
nouvel argument qui est et on a une dent
de das plétosor qui est nickel c'est
Apple problème quand il y a qu'un seul
échantillon comme ça c'est que on sait
pas comment il a été sélectionné est-ce
que vous êtes allé chercher là dans la
mieux préservée pour pouvoir dire pour
pouvoir conclure ça ou bien est-ce que
c'est vraiment une banque que vous avez
pris au pifomètre
je pense pas que c'est une dent qu'ils
ont pris au pifomètre parce qu'ils sont
allés la chercher dans un crâne c'est
même pas une dent isolée c'est une dent
qui sont allés prélever dans un crâne ça
par contre il le disent dans l'article
donc ils n'ont pas pris au pifomètre
cette dent bon
donc pour conclure
les Paléo artistes devez-vous ou pas
représenter vos dinosaures avec des
lèvres on ne sait pas on ne le sait
toujours pas
et cet article là n'apporte que des de
nouveaux argueux enfin un nouvel
argument en la faveur de la présence de
lèvres mais en aucun cas ne démontre
l'existence de lèvres la démonstration
de l'existence de lèvres ou pas ne se
fera que par la découverte d'un fossile
préservant les tissus de la face donc
pour l'instant si vous n'êtes pas Léo
artistes et que vous écoutez Paléo news
en ce moment qu'est-ce que vous devez
faire bah vous avez le droit de faire ce
que vous voulez vous avez le droit de
faire l'un ou l'autre et personne n'a le
droit de vous dire que c'est pas
scientifique de ne pas mettre de lèvres
en vous collant cet article dans le nez
parce que si on vous colle cet article
dans le nez vous pouvez coller ma vidéo
sous leur nez à eux je vous autorise à
leur coller cette vidéo sous leur nez en
réalité même j'ai envie de dire
qu'est-ce qui est le plus scientifique
et là c'est pas c'est pas une un truc
pour obliger les Paléo artistes à faire
ce que je veux c'est vraiment juste pour
vous dire vous avez le droit de faire ce
que vous voulez en tant que Paléo
artiste vous avez le droit à la licence
artistique maintenant si vous voulez
faire quelque chose de scientifiquement
correct qu'est-ce que vous devez faire
si vous voulez faire quelque chose de
scientifiquement correct sachez que il y
a pas un mot de trop dans ce que je vais
dire sachez que en l'absence de preuve
formelle de l'existence de lèvres chez
tyrannosaure ou chez n'importe quel
autre théropode
rajoutez des lèvres c'est faire une
hypothèse de trop c'est faire une
hypothèse
inutile or la science fonctionne au
maximum de parcimonie la science
fonctionne à l'économie d'hypothèse de
trop
donc si vous voulez être réellement
scientifique si vous voulez avoir le
petit cache ton ping scientifiquement
correct
faut pas mettre de lèvres
voilà c'est c'est la science la plus
pure possible que vous pouvez imaginer
là on est sur de l'épistémologie de base
si vous voulez faire de la science si
vous voulez le petit cacheton
scientifiquement correct il faut
économiser les hypothèses c'est ça la
scientificité c'est ça la garantie de
scientificité d'une reconstruction parce
que si vous vous mettez à rajouter des
trucs par dessus alors oui vous allez
rajouter des lèvres et c'est tout à fait
innocent et comme j'ai dit ça n'a aucune
espèce d'importance paléobiologique vous
allez rajouter des lèvres c'est
parfaitement innocent mais avec la même
logique qui vous a fait rajouter des
lèvres bah pourquoi vous rajoutez pas
des cornes pourquoi vous rajoutez pas
des plumes partout et pourquoi vous
rajoutez pas de la viande jusqu'à ce que
votre T-Rex soit plus qu'un squelette de
T-Rex dans une énorme boule de viande
c'est qu'à partir du moment où on
s'autorise à rajouter des hypothèses de
trop
et bah il y a plus rien qui en fait vous
ouvrez les vannes à une forme de logique
qui vous permettrait de rajouter de la
viande à l'infini en fait alors
peut-être que les peut-être que la
logique scientifique a tort dans ce
cas-là c'est vrai c'est possible
peut-être que ça là peut-être que
l'élève c'est la vraie condition
peut-être que la logique scientifique a
tort mais la logique scientifique veut
qu'on travaille à l'économie d'hypothèse
jusqu'à preuve du contraire les
dinosaures n'ont pas de l'oeuvre point
et donc au moment de prendre la décision
on va dire au moment d'appliquer le
rasoir de came la favorisoir de cam et
ben on tranche et on coupe les lèvres
parce que c'est exactement ça c'est le
rasoir de Cam c'est l'économie
d'hypothèse
voilà donc ça c'est mon petit avis sur
cet article alors je pense comme je l'ai
dit il rajoute des arguments dans la
balance enfin il rajoute un argument
dans la balance une seule danse et un
argument assez faible personnellement et
je sais pas si ça va si ça va aller
vraiment d'être publié dans Saiyan comme
j'ai dit cet argument là c'est du c'est
du réchauffé cet argument là c'était
c'était pas le meilleur argument d'un
contre la présence de lèvres on continue
avec les dinosaures carnivores avec un
article qui date de 2021 mais qui a eu
des news donc alors attends c'est une
histoire un peu compliquée alors on va
la commencer du début donc l'article que
j'ai vu passer cette année qui date en
réalité enfin qui vient d'être publié
mais qui a été soumis en 2022 mais
publiée en mars 2023 c'est un article en
gros qui nous dit Allosaurus était
principalement un charognard à l'osaurus
était principalement un charognard et ça
c'était c'est un article je sais pas
pourquoi c'est c'est juste une réponse
en fait cet article a un autre article
qui est sorti en 2021 et que je sais pas
pourquoi je l'ai raté donc ça m'arrive
des fois dans ma vie scientifique pour
peu que ce soit quand j'étais sur le
terrain par exemple ben j'ai raté la
sortie de cet article et donc c'est à
l'osaurus qui serait principalement un
charognard et donc ce qu'ils avaient
utilisé à l'époque en 2021 donc c'est
l'article que je vais vous mettre
maintenant
voici leur article de 2021
paru dans ecological modeling et donc
comme vous voyez ça va être de la
modélisation écologique ça va être de
des trucs qu'on met dans un ordinateur à
mon dîner comme ça donc ce qu'ils
avaient fait en fait c'est qu'ils
avaient modélisé le régime alimentaire
possible des dinosaures de la formation
Morrison pas seulement de Allosaurus
mais j'imagine que le nouvel article qui
est une réponse à une réponse de
quelqu'un d'autre ça commence à ça
commence à tirer à balle réel et à
commencer à employer des punchlines en
guise de titre plutôt que des arguments
on va dire plutôt que des titres
raisonnables mais bref passons donc cet
article sorti en 2021
utiliser de la modélisation écologique
pour nous dire que
que les théropodes de la formation
Morrison était pas forcément des
carnivores mais pouvait tout aussi bien
avoir été des charognards et cette
modélisation écologique se basait sur un
truc tout simple que tout le monde a
observé enfin que tous les
paléontologues ont observé dans la
formation Morrison et tout ce sont
grattés la tête en se demandant mais
qu'est-ce qui est en train de se passer
avec ça c'est que dans la formation
Morrison il y a beaucoup beaucoup trop
de soropodes alors je sais pas il faut
arriver à se représenter déjà c'est que
les se reposent en soit leur propre
existence donc les sauropodes ce sont
les dinosaures à long cou hein ce sont
ces grosses bêtes là
c'est soropodes déjà alors leur masse
leur poids gigantesque 30 tonnes ou plus
jusqu'à 70 tonnes voire même 100 tonnes
si vous écoutez certains ça a été estimé
même pour brachiosaure ça a été estimé
jusqu'à 180 tonnes bon c'était n'importe
quoi mais vous voyez le voyez l'idée les
soropodes c'est du n'importe quoi niveau
biologique on ne sait pas comment il
fonctionne on arrive à avoir une vague
idée en faisant ci en faisant ça ils
avaient des membres en colonne ok ils
avaient des poches d'air dans les
vertèbres ok ça les ça les a légère un
peu il devait avoir une biologie et un
métabolisme assez bas histoire de pas
surchauffer il devait bouger très très
lentement histoire de pas se casser les
os etc ok on arrive à mettre ensemble
des éléments biologiques pour arriver à
plus ou moins comprendre comment ils
arrivaient à pas crever mais comment ils
arrivaient à vivre c'est c'est un truc
qui nous échappe complètement comment
ils ont eu un tel succès évolutif c'est
un truc qui nous échappe complètement
comment ne serait-ce qu'ils arrivaient à
se monter dessus pour se reproduire
c'est comment ces bêtes là comment
trente tonnes de chair arriver à
escalader une autre montagne de 30
tonnes de chair et en plus à lui mettre
son petit zigoui façon géant ce gouigoui
en l'occurrence pour arriver à la
féconder et le tout sans lui exploser le
bassin et les vertèbres
on ne sait pas donc déjà l'existence
même en soit des soropodes est un
mystère c'est là où je vais en venir
c'est déjà c'est dur à comprendre
comment c'est bestioles là arrivait à ne
serait-ce que survivre et encore pire à
avoir un véritable succès évolutif mais
en plus
en plus dans la formation Morrison il y
a quasiment 20 espèces différentes
s'il y a un nombre fou de ces animaux
dans la formation Morrison bon il y en a
peut-être que 10 mais même 10 je dis
vous imaginez c'est des c'est des
tondeuses à gazon de 30 tonnes qui se
déplacent
peut-être tout seul peut-être en
troupeau peu importe qui tombe tout je
veux dire quand vous voyez le bordel que
fou une horde d'éléphant dans ça vous
transforme une forêt en savane en
seulement deux mois
imaginez 20 10 ou 20 espèces de
soropodes en Amérique du Nord à l'époque
de la formation Morrison donc au
Jurassique
en train de tout tondre et de tout
défoncer et c'est de la folie c'est de
la folie à imaginer donc on est au
milieu de cette folie ambiante de la
formation Morrison où il y a trop
d'animaux trop gros pour que ça
fonctionne
et au milieu de ça on a des petits
dinosaures carnivores enfin petit un
Allosaure c'est quand même c'est une
belle bête mais en comparaison d'avoir
acquisosaure comme vous voyez là ça
reste du petit et donc au milieu de ça
vous avez des carnivores et ces
carnivores en fait ce que ce que propose
cet article ni plus ni moins c'est de
dire bah au milieu de ce bordel
l'ambiance les carnivores ils avaient
qu'à servir
en réalité parce qu'il y avait une telle
biomasse d'animaux qui devait mourir de
façon constante à des âges relativement
différents
notamment parce qu'on sait que les
soropodes pondaient beaucoup d'eux donc
ils étaient comme les tortues c'était
des stratèges R pour reproduction donc
il se reproduisent beaucoup et puis
inchallah s'il y en a un ou deux qui
survivent vous pondez 200 œufs et puis
on verra bien si on a un ou deux qui
survivent jusqu'à l'âge adulte donc il y
avait une manne de petits de petits
soropodes que les prédateurs pouvaient
voilà pouvaient servir quoi donc c'est
pas vraiment de la chasse de haut vol on
va dire et puis à côté de ça vous avez
une biomasse d'adulte qui devait mourir
tout le temps
c'est le cycle c'est le grand cycle de
la vie Simba leur corps se transforme en
herbe et les antilopes l'herbe non je
dis je commence à délirer
donc il y avait une beaucoup de ces
grands européropodes qui devaient mourir
de façon constante parce que bah ça
meurt au bout d'un moment elle se repose
mais il y a pas besoin de beaucoup de
soropodes morts pour nourrir et pour
maintenir une population de grands
aéropodes en fait et c'est ça la
modélisation qu'ils ont faites c'est que
en gros donc là en modèle ce qu'ils
disent c'est que si vous avez des halles
aux Orres et autres théropodes donc les
carnosaures ici en vert qui mangent qui
sont des prédateurs en fait bah leur
population elle se pétrit la gueule à
une vitesse formidable parce que c'est
hyper dangereux de s'attaquer à ce
repose ou même à stégosaure à l'époque
avait aussi des stégosaures c'est hyper
dangereux de s'attaquer à un théropode à
Soro pod ou même un stégosaure en fait
donc leur population se pétrir
rapidement la gueule alors que s'ils
étaient simplement
charognard donc ici la ligne en rose et
bien là pour leur population elle
décollerait
parce que il y aurait juste une quantité
phénoménale de nourriture accessible
sans aucun effort et ce qu'ils disent
c'est que si on estime la taille enfin
le volume d'un foie de de soropodes d'un
foie de diplodocus ou de brachiosaure il
y avait suffisamment de calories à
l'intérieur rien que dans le foie d'un
seauropode il y avait suffisamment de
calories enfin il y avait plus de
calories que dans un stégosaure entier
c'est à dire pourquoi tu vas aller te
faire chier à aller tuer à stégosaure
alors que tu as juste à trouver un
diplodocus mort
et sachant qu'il y a une manne de
diplodocus mort tout le temps dans le
dans les parages et que tu es pas
forcément obligé d'en manger que le foie
en plus alors là on s'arrête que sur le
foie parce que c'est l'organe le plus le
plus riche mais évidemment tu es pas
obligé de manger que le foie
et je trouve ça enfin sans être
forcément hyper d'accord avec l'idée
parce que je suis pas non plus un grand
expert des dinosaures ni de la formation
Morrison en particulier mais sans non
plus être complètement d'accord avec
l'idée je trouve que l'idée est
vachement séduisante parce que là cette
elle a cette simplicité séduisante en
fait qui est bah oui il y a un max de
carcasse de trucs gigantesque il y a de
la viande partout basiquement
et les carnivores ils peuvent survivre
mettons deux semaines sans se nourrir
ils peuvent bien pendant deux semaines
comme ça se balader
tranquillou sans courir tu vois à la
recherche et puis tu sais de temps en
temps ils vont renifler une carcasse ils
vont faire ah c'est par là et puis poum
poum poum et puis voilà puis ils vont
arriver sur la carcasse et puis se
nourrir un machin on a cette on a ce
dépôt où on a effectivement des pleins
de carcasses d'herbivores qui sont
entourés de plein de carcasses de
carnivores qui est-ce qu'on appelle ce
qu'on appelle un piège un piège à
prédateur alors on appelle ça un piège à
prédateur mais en réalité c'est plus un
piège à charognard c'est-à-dire que
c'est un genre de marre de boue dans
laquelle des stégosaures et d'autres
dinosaures herbivores se sont enlisés
qui datent du Jurassic aussi donc des
dinosaures se sont enlisés et en fait il
y a des carnivores qui se sont empilés
par dessus à force de venir charronnier
les carcasses et sans liser eux même
dans la boue donc ça ça irait bien dans
le sens de
d'achat rognage un autre argument qui va
aussi dans le sens du d'un charognage
possible c'est que contrairement à
Tyrannosaurus
au Jurassique on a quasiment aucune
trace dedans enfin contrairement au
tyrannosauridé du Crétacé pour lesquels
on a plein de traces dedans dont des
traces de prédation c'est à dire des
traces de prédation ratées de des traces
dedans qui se sont ensuite cicatrisés
qui montrent que l'animal était vivant
quand il a été attaqué pas seulement des
traces de dents sur les os qui ont été
faites post mortem mais aussi des traces
dedans qui ont été faites du vivant de
la proie et qui ont cicatrisé donc ça on
en a plein aux crétacés on en a
quasiment pas pour le Jurassic et pas
pour la formation Morrison mais en tout
cas c'est c'est une idée qui est
intéressante en tout cas qui est qui qui
donne à réfléchir je trouve et c'est
pour ça que je la trouve marrante cette
idée et je trouve bizarre que je que je
l'ai raté parce que finalement c'est
marrant c'est marrant et ils discute
aussi de la possibilité que oui
effectivement il y avait pas
d'adaptation à la prédation franche chez
par exemple à l'osaurus
Allosaurus vous voyez comparé à
tyrannosaure qui a un gros crâne très
massif avec une morsure très puissante à
l'inverse à l'osaurus il a plutôt un
crâne hyper étroit et il a pas de vision
binoculaire c'est ce qui est représenté
ici voyez le champ binoculaire n'est que
de 20 degrés alors que le champ
binoculaire chez
Tyrannosaurus être 60 degrés donc il a
pas de vision binoculaire et il a un
crâne plutôt léger avec une morsure très
très faible et et du coup ça ça peut
donner à penser qu'il était qu'il était
pas spécialement prédateur alors
généralement c'est plutôt interprété
comme étant c'était un prédateur mais
plutôt à faire des blessures en fait
affliger des blessures jusqu'à ce que la
proie décède de ces de ses blessures
donc perdre son sang et décèdes de ses
blessures alors que tyrannosaure c'était
plutôt une morsure gagnante c'est plutôt
ça l'interprétation classique il y en a
certains qui vont proposer évidemment
que tyrannosaure était aussi
en comparaison avec les hyènes était
aussi un charognard parce qu'il avait
une mâchoire broyeuse d'os ben avoir une
mâchoire broyeuse dose vous qualifie pas
forcément à la au charognage ça peut
aussi vouloir dire que vous chopiez les
machins et que vous leur broyer les eaux
quand ils étaient vivants ça marche
aussi
bref donc ils discute tout ça et donc la
base de tout ça c'est quand même la
modélisation qui dit que il y a
tellement de ce reposes qui devait
mourir à longueur de temps que au final
pourquoi tu veux être chasseur quoi
pourquoi tu veux t'embêter avec chasseur
et d'ailleurs étant donné le risque et
étant donné le risque qu'ils ont inclus
dans leur modèle de s'attaquer à son
repas d'adulte ou un stégosaure ou
n'importe quoi c'était probablement pas
profitable de s'attaquer à des d'être
prédateurs en réalité valait mieux être
charognard attendre qu'il crève tout
seul et puis et puis se nourrir de la
carcasse et notamment du foie qui était
hyper riche donc j'aime beaucoup cet
article parce que je le trouve très je
trouve la je le trouve très provocante
très original je dis pas forcément
qu'ils ont raison et puis comme j'ai dit
il y a un débat c'est à dire que ça
m'est complètement passé sous le nez
pour une raison une autre mais il y a un
débat c'est à dire que là l'article que
j'ai vu sortir ici là celui-là
qui est sorti donc cette année en mars
2023 c'est la réponse à une réponse qui
avait été faite à l'article de 2021 donc
c'est à dire qu'ils sont en train de se
tirer dessus là
ils sont en train de se tirer dessus
pour savoir qui a raison qui a tort je
vous invite à lire ces articles si ça
vous intéresse les liens seront en
description pour télécharger les PDF on
continue avec les dinosaures avec cette
nouvelle étude publiée dans The
anatomikal records un ankylosaure donc
le nom de genre c'est tarchia donc
tarchia qui est un ankylosaure du
Crétacé de Mongolie qui a été scanné
donc passé au rayon X et à l'intérieur
de de son crâne en fait je pense qu'il
visait à étudier les canaux des nasaux
en fait parce qu'on sait que chez les
ankylosaures le conduit nasal fait des
boucs et des machins super inutiles et
on se demande encore pourquoi le conduit
nasal des ankylosaures était si
compliqué donc je pense que l'idée de
base c'était d'étudier ça pourquoi le
conduit nasal des ankylosaures est si
compliqué et en fait ce qu'ils ont
trouvé à l'intérieur du compte du nasal
d'ankylosaure c'est cette espèce
d'énormes masse vous voyez là vous avez
une narine à peu près saine ici et là
vous avez le conduit nasal qui ne l'est
pas du tout
parce qu'en fait il y a eu une espèce de
ponctuation qui a été fait ici dans l'os
alors ponctuation en anglais mais
vraiment une genre de trou il y a un
trou qui a été fait du vivant de
l'animal dans l'os ici à la surface et
donc ce que vous voyez sur la section de
cette narine bah c'est que dans la
narine ici il y a une énorme masse
osseuse hyper dense qui s'est développée
et ça c'est une énorme pathologie donc
là vous voyez différentes tranches à
l'intérieur du crâne on voit cette masse
qui s'est développée à l'intérieur de la
narine c'est une masse osseuse c'est une
pathologie
qui s'est développée dans les naseaux à
cause probablement de cette de cette
blessure qui a été faite ici au niveau
de la narine
c'est ce qu'on appelle c'est ce qu'on
appelle un gros calus ça calus une une
pathologie une pathologie de l'os ici
vous les voyez en représentés en 3D
c'était énormément masse ils appellent
ça une masse
à l'intérieur du passage des narines
voyez que les narines d'ailleurs au
passage sont c'est compliqué ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur ça fait des boucles
ça fait des machins et ce qu'il propose
en fait c'est que bah là vous aviez donc
un trou là le fameux petit trou ici
roule donc vous aviez un trou ici et en
dessous de se trou il y a cette énorme
surdéveloppement cette hyper trophie
osseuse qui sont l'indication en fait
d'une d'une pathologie d'une infection
de l'os donc il y a eu blessure et il y
a eu ensuite infection donc là on voit
un petit peu mieux la blessure en
question ici il y a eu blessure il y a
eu affection et puis l'os s'est mis à
grandir de façon exponentielle sans
aucune raison un peu comme un peu comme
une tumeur c'est pas vraiment une tumeur
mais c'est un peu comme une tumeur c'est
l'OS ne sait plus quoi faire en fait
pour guérir l'infection se redéveloppe
l'os se redéveloppe par dessus et
l'infection entre développe etc etc
et donc le et puis bah au final l'animal
a dû finir par en mourir parce que on
voit pas de signe que l'infection c'est
résorbée donc l'infection était encore
en cours quand l'animal est mort
et du coup c'est probablement ça qu'il
l'a tué parce que vous voyez là là vous
avez le cerveau ici vous avez
l'infection ici donc l'infection était
vraiment pas loin du cerveau et donc
elle n'avait pas et comme l'os était
touché si vous voulez là le
potentiellement vous voyez le signe de
l'infection ici mais potentiellement
c'est tout l'os aux alentours qui était
complètement rempli de pus ça devait
être absolument fabuleux ils ont pas
fait de reconstruction curieusement ils
ont pas fait de reconstruction Paléo
artistique de cette condition mais en
gros vous deviez avoir un espèce de trou
dans sa narine là à ce niveau là qui
devait supérer un espèce de liquide
jaunâtre noir immonde et vous deviez
avoir la narine aussi ici qui devait
dégouliner d'un espèce de mucus horrible
ceintant la mort
et des mouches ah des mouches
ça y est j'ai l'image
et des mouches partout qui pondent leurs
cochonneries
qui pondent leur cochonneries de de
larves des petits des petits asticots
partout là en train de lui bouffer les
narines vivants ah ça devait être
magnifique
ça devait être beau avoir c'est ça le
monde sans antibiotique mesdames et
messieurs
rappelez-vous c'était pas Yassine
c'était il y a 200 ans le monde sans
antibiotique vous avez un trou dans le
pif et ça peut donner ça là cette espèce
de masse dégueulasse heureusement
aujourd'hui on a plus que
mais ça devait être immonde à regarder
ça devait lui sortir par l'oeil aussi
c'est tellement proche de l'oeil aussi
et donc la cause de la mort probablement
ça a été que l'infection s'est propagée
jusqu'au cerveau donc le cerveau il est
là en bleu
donc probablement le l'affection a pu se
propager jusqu'au cerveau à travers le
les bulles olfactifs
et ou à travers l'os directement si ça
se trouve dans les ménages vous avez une
méningite infection des méninges est
mort quoi donc voilà pauvre petit
ankylosaure et donc ce qu'il y a
d'intéressant avec ça c'est pas
seulement la l'image merveilleuse que je
viens de vous dépeindre c'est surtout
qui est qui a fait que qui a eu un trou
dans la tête pourquoi qu'il a un trou
dans la tête cet ankylosaure bah on sait
pas que cette pathologie finalement
c'est une trace fossile d'une activité
qui a eu lieu sur la tête de ce pauvre
animal et quelle activité bah ça c'est
la grande question et deux hypothèses
sont proposées dans l'article mais ils
préfèrent quand même l'hypothèse d'une
prédation à savoir que le trouble là que
vous voyez ici c'est quand même un bien
gros joli trou de assection enfin pointu
au bout et assection rectangulaire ça
sent le tyrannosaure idée
donc là en l'occurrence on est en
Mongolie donc ce serait le Tarbosaurus
ça sent fort le Tarbosaurus ceci étant
dit il est possible que puisqu'on l'a vu
la dernière fois les ankylosaures on a
vu maintenant on a des on commence à
accumuler des preuves comme quoi il se
battait avec leur queue de tête bêche
et vous imaginez bien que si leur tête
est blindée c'est pas pour rien c'est
qu'il devait de temps en temps prendre
des coups de cœur en plein dans leur
mouilles vu qu'il se battait tête bêche
et qu'il s'envoyait des coups de queue
du coup dans la tête direction leur tête
et direction leur flancs les côtes à ce
niveau là
donc il est possible aussi que se trouve
ce soit un trou du à une un combat entre
mal il est possible aussi que ce soit un
coup de boule entre mal peut-être que
les mâles aussi peut-être qu'une autre
raison pour laquelle les les
ankylosaures ont la tête blindé c'est
parce qu'ils se mettait les coups de
boules encore que c'est ça rarement été
proposé mais bon pourquoi pas après tout
ils ont des petites cornes là sur le la
sauce squame ici ils auraient pu se
mettre des coups de cornes comme ça vous
voyez là les petites cornes sur le côté
c'est pas complètement impossible qu'ils
aient pu se mettre des petites coups de
cornes mais en tout cas voilà c'est les
deux hypothèses qu'il propose ici soit
le combat intra spécifique donc entre
mal supposément entre mal on n'est pas
capable de dire qu'elles étaient les
mâles et qu'elles étaient les femelles
mais
combattre un spécifique et l'autre c'est
évidemment acte de prédation sachant
qu'il privilégie quand même l'acte de
prédation parce que vous voyez qu'il y a
pas qu'une seule enfin il y a un gros
trou certes mais il y a d'autres traces
de
il y a d'autres traces en fait sur le
sommet du crâne qui semble indiquer que
effectivement on a peut-être un arc de
cercle qui serait assez cohérent
finalement avec une morsure un arc de
cercle de pathologies qui serait
cohérent avec une morsure donc un
fossile très intéressant et puis encore
une fois très vivant c'est à dire que le
fossile il est mort mais l'histoire
qu'il nous raconte c'est très vivant et
c'est ça qui a de bien avec les traces
fossiles et puis bah du coup vu qu'on
parle de trace fossile nous passons
désormais à la revue PLoS ONE dans
lequel mes collègues Sud-Africains ont
publié une nouvelle étude d'une trace
fossile en fait d'une grande surface
couverte de trace possible vous voyez il
y a il y a un petit monsieur ici donc
qui vous donne l'échelle quand même de
de la taille de cette trace fossile
enfin de cette surface couverte de trace
fossile et alors sur cette surface de
trace fossile il y a notamment des
empreintes des des rites de courant donc
il montre que ça a été formé sous une
faible épaisseur d'eau
et parmi ces empreintes vous avez ça
vous voyez ici là une longue queue le
corps et la tête une longue queue le
corps la tête une langue que le corps la
tête une longue que le corps la tête ce
sont des empreintes qui datent du
Permien supérieur et qui ont été faites
par un amphibien enfin un ou plusieurs
en l'occurrence en phybien et alors ce
qu'il y a d'intéressant avec ces traces
d'amphibiens c'est que elles ont été
faites sous une faible tranche d'eau
donc en fait ce qu'on voit c'est un
amphibien qui nage enfin qui ne nage pas
mais qui marche au fond de l'eau et qui
se repose plouf et là ça imprime son
corps dans la vase et ensuite il marche
sur l'eau et de temps en temps il fait
des changements de direction très très
abruptes vous voyez ici la changement de
direction très très abrupte c'est comme
un vol d'oiseau friend un prédateur non
c'est comme un amphibien marchant dans
le fond de la vase
c'est magnifique
et c'est et c'est ça aussi ça indique
évidemment que l'amphibien marchait au
fond de la vase c'est que un changement
de direction pareil
c'est difficilement possible pour un
animal aussi lourd qu'un techno spondyl
ce que j'ai une échelle parce qu'il faut
quand même que je vous convaincre c'est
assez gros mais c'est assez gros quand
même là la barre d'échelle elle est de
30 cm ici donc vous voyez la longueur du
machin c'est quand même quasiment à
mettre un mètre 30 voire peut-être un
mètre 1m80 quoi c'est une belle c'est
une belle empreinte quoi c'est une belle
bête qui a fait ça donc un animal de
cette taille là avec les bras sur le
côté qui fait un changement un
changement de direction aussi abrupte
c'est quand même c'est quand même peu
c'est quand même peu probable qu'il ait
fait ça à l'air libre donc là on est sur
plutôt des empreintes qui ont été faits
en dessous de l'eau
et regardez un peu comment comment en
plus c'est quasiment sûr que c'est un
teemon spondyl enfin que c'est un
amphibien diagnostic parce que là on a
vraiment l'empreinte du corps elle est
parfaite avec le museau arrondi
exactement comme on a pour les
amphibiens de l'époque les amphibiens
qui vivaient il y a
255 millions d'années on est à la toute
fin du permis là donc c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment impressionnant et là
c'est comparé à une empreinte de
crocodile faite sous les mêmes
conditions
la correspondance est de oufissime à
part les écailles là on voit bien les
écailles sur le crocodile là il y a pas
des cailles en dessous du corps ce qui
confirme aussi la police la police de
cette et nos spondylle de ses amphibiens
on s'attend pas à trouver des écailles
chez les amphibiens du Permien donc
c'est quand même une découverte assez
officielle assez belle et en plus elle a
été faite ce qu'il y a d'intéressant
aussi niveau géologique c'est que c'est
une empreinte qui a été c'est ce sont
des empreintes cette surface d'empreinte
elle a été faite
dans un groupement qui s'appelle le cas
et en fait les cas un groupement de
roche on est encore en système de
groupement chez les chez les Suds
africains dans la géologie sud-africaine
on fait plus tellement ça en Europe le
système regroupement mais enfin c'est un
groupement de roches qui s'appelle les
cas et qui a été fait en sédiment marin
et qui est en dessous du Beaufort et le
beaufort c'est là où on trouve tous les
dissinodontes les gorgonopsiens les
machins c'est le c'est le cas où typique
dont je vous parle tout le temps donc le
chaos typique dont je vous parle tout le
temps normalement il est au-dessus de
l'écart
mais en fait le truc c'est que le
carreau typique le beaufort il démarre
au permis moyen
au sud-ouest du bassin mais il démarre
au permis supérieur au nord-est du
bassin et donc là ce que la présence de
sténose spondyl indique c'est que au
nord-est du bassin là où c'est là où ça
se trouve là dans le quasulu Natal au
nord-est du bassin en fait on a déjà une
faune qui correspond à celle du Permien
supérieur donc en fait
c'est pas c'est pas seulement que les
cas est plus ancien que le Beaufort en
fait le contact entre le Beaufort et les
cas c'est pas un contact
stratigraphique dans le sens
chronologique c'est une ligne de rivage
en fait les cas et le beaufort sont du
même âge ce sont deux formations
différentes on trouve systématiquement
le beaufort au dessus de l'écart mais en
réalité ils sont du même âge
ouais c'est chaud c'est chaud à
comprendre c'est chaud à comprendre mais
en gros ce qu'on a c'est juste un
changement de palais en fait ce qu'il
faut vous imaginer c'est que le beaufort
c'est un Paléo environnement terrestre
alors que les cas c'est un
paléo-environnement marin et donc cet
amphibien là ce qui vous montre c'est en
chimiac on pense être un stéréo spondyl
parce que déjà c'est un gros amphibien
et qu'en plus il est marin il est dans
un environnement marin donc ça
correspond à la description des stéréo
spondyles mais en fait ce que cette
amphibien vous indique c'est que on est
au Permien supérieur en fait c'est les
stéréo spondyle on les trouve dans le
Permien supérieur c'est là là ils sont
même allés jusqu'à l'identifier comme
étant riné succus
le faiseur de cette empreinte donc ils
sont même allé très très loin dans la
détermination le genre riné succus et
donc ce que ça montre en fait c'est que
si vous avez riné succus bah ça vous
montre en fait que les cas n'est pas
plus vieux que le Beaufort en dessous
duquel il se trouve il est du même âge
et donc la ligne entre les deux c'est
pas une ligne stratigraphique c'est en
réalité une ligne de rivage vous passez
d'un environnement marin à un envie d'en
rendement terrestre et c'est cool et
c'est de la folie moi je trouve que
c'est de la folie
c'est de la folie en fait d'avoir deux
formations l'une au-dessus de l'autre
mais en fait elles sont du même âge moi
je trouve ça bon
évidemment faut être géologue pour
trouver ça ouf mais
voilà
et on termine enfin avec cette article
sur le tilacine on va parler on va
parler cryptoologie on l'a fait la
dernière fois aussi avec avec notre
article sur le sasquatch comme quoi le
sasquatch c'était en fait un ours ben là
on a un article sur le tilacine cette
fois le thylacine qui est le loup de
Tasmanie le loup marsupial
convergence magnifique exemple de
convergence évolutive avec les
carnivores canidés mais en réalité
c'était un petit marsupial c'est un
proche parent des kangourous il vivait
en Australie et en Tasmanie il a disparu
d'Australie mais survivait en Tasmanie
jusqu'à ce qu'on le chasse à mort dans
les années 1800 fin des années 1800 et
début des années 1930 et si bien que le
dernier spécimen connu qui était dans un
zoo
est mort en 1936
s'élan la disparition de ce thilassine
point d'interrogation
rajoute cet article donc cet article
paru dans Science of the totall on va
que je ne connaissais pas mais bon c'est
elle sévir donc c'est
article donc c'est une modélisation en
fait de la disparition du tilacine donc
de la réduction de la population du
tilacine qui nous suggère que peut-être
le tilacine aurait survécu jusque dans
les années 80
voire même jusqu'aux années 2000 selon
les selon les modélisations qu'ils ont
réalisé les plus les plus optimistes
alors comment qui sont arrivés là bah
c'est là que ça pêche je trouve enfin
c'est là que ça devient de la vraie
cryptoologie c'est qu'ils ont utilisé
les témoignages
parce qu'il y a une grande base de
données évidemment des témoignages de
tilacine qui ont été de témoignages de
gens qui ont cru avoir vu des thylacine
qui qui existent ça existe il y a une
grande base de données qui existe de ça
comme il y a une grande base de données
de gens qui ont vu des Bigfoot
et cette grande base de données ils
l'ont utilisé pour modéliser
l'extinction du tilacine alors ils sont
pas ça reste de la bonne science dans le
sens où ils ont pas donné le même niveau
de crédibilité à tous les témoignages
dans leur modèle donc ils ont quand même
tenu compte du niveau de crédibilité des
témoignages dans leur modèle
mais sachant enfin
comment dire pour eux un témoignage
crédible c'est un témoignage donné par
un Ranger encore une fois
qu'appelle-t-on un témoignage
qu'appelle-t-on un témoignage fiable tu
vois il y a des Rangers en Amérique du
Nord qui ont cru avoir vu des Bigfoot
donc bon
la question que je me suis posée en
lisant cet article c'est si vous aviez
mis les données du Bigfoot dans votre
modèle ça aurait été quoi la date
d'extinction du Bigfoot selon vous
quelle aurait été la taille de
population actuelle du Bigfoot selon
vous si vous aviez mis la base de
données des témoignages de Bigfoot dans
le même modèle
donc ouais je suis pas je suis pas
convaincu que le thylacine se soit
éteint dans les années 80 et encore
moins dans les années 2000 et je suis
pas convaincu de l'approche qui consiste
à utiliser les témoignages tout
simplement parce que les témoignages
c'est si peu fiable c'est si peu fiable
les témoignages j'arrête pas de
reprendre tout le temps les mecs les
mêmes exemples qui avaient été publiés
dans nightcher of the beast du
généticien daikes et qui disait il y a
quand même des chasseurs expérimentés
qui ont tué un ours l'ont pris pour un
Bigfoot et ont tué un ours ont pris le
temps d'enterrer la carcasse de l'ours
et quand on est venu faire les analyses
génétiques on leur a dit mais non les
gars c'est un ours c'est pas un Bigfoot
c'est à dire les dégâts étaient
convaincus d'avoir tué un Bigfoot ils
l'ont enterré donc ils ont été en
contact avec la bestiole très proche de
dire chasseur ou pas chasseur ranger
même touristes à ce niveau-là vous voyez
un ours normalement vous savez ce que
vous regardez bah non vous avez des
rencontres comme ça où les gars ont été
aussi proche que tu puisses l'être de
l'animal et ils ont toujours pas reconnu
que c'était un ours ils étaient
persuadés que c'était un Bigfoot c'est
le généticien qui est venu qui a fait
des analyses génétiques sur la carcasse
et qui a dit non c'est un ours
il y a des il y a une personne qui a
percuté une vache avec sa voiture qui
était convaincue que c'était un Bigfoot
alors que c'était une vache
une vache
bon ok il faisait nuit mais quand même
tu percutes une vache et tes convaincu
d'avoir touché un animal qui ressemble à
un gorille voire même à un humain poilu
c'est donc oui les témoignages les
témoignages c'est pas bon c'est pas du
bon matériel en tout cas moi je
considère pas le témoignage comme du bon
matériel donc c'est pour ça que je me
demande la quand le quand la le jus que
tu insères dans ton modèle ton jus de
base c'est du témoignage est-ce que le
est-ce que ce que tu en tires de ton
modèle c'est quelque chose de fiable moi
je pense pas donc dans leur dans leur
modèle le plus
conservatif on va dire dans leur modèle
le plus qui colle le plus
avec les rencontres les véritables
rencontres avec des thylacines
c'est-à-dire des rencontres identifiées
avec un tilacine la dernière datant de
1937 parce que oui le dernier tilacine
en captivité est mort en 1936 mais il y
a eu une capture de thylacine sauvage en
1937 donc ce qui montre qu'il y avait
encore une toute petite bah c'est même
pas une population à ce niveau-là il
restait encore d'éthylacine mais
fonctionnellement le bazar était éteint
depuis déjà longtemps en fait
l'extinction fonctionnelle
contrairement à l'extinction ferme et
définitive quand on dit qu'une expert
qu'une espèce est fonctionnellement
éteinte ça veut dire que la population
est trop petite pour se re-développer
c'est à dire que même c'est même pas dit
que l'éthylacine et eu l'occasion même
ne serait-ce que de se rencontrer pour
s'accoupler et de toute façon la
diversité génétique aurait été trop
faible donc vous pouvez toujours avoir
cinq animaux qui qui courent en Tasmanie
l'espèce est fonctionnellement éteinte
parce que de toute façon ils
n'arriveront pas à se reproduire et même
s'ils y arrivent la diversité génétique
est trop faible donc le c'est la
consanguinité qui les flinguera les
modèles les plus réalistes selon moi le
thylacine s'est éteint en 1941 ou en
tout cas dans les années 40 ce qui est
cohérent avec le fait que le dernier
tilacine capturé sa date de 1937 et
l'espèce était probablement déjà
fonctionnellement éteinte à ce moment là
quoi
non bref mais c'est intéressant de voir
du coup comment des données
cryptosiologiques peuvent être traités
de façon scientifique de cette façon là
parce que là c'est vraiment de la donnée
cryptose crypto de type cryptoologie
pure c'est du témoignage c'est le c'est
vraiment le jus de la cryptoologie c'est
un truc un autre truc intéressant qui a
dans cet article et je crois que c'est
probablement même le truc le plus
intéressant de cet article du point de
vue cryptoologique c'est que
contrairement à la plupart des crepides
pour lesquels le nombre de vues a
augmenté avec l'arrivée des smartphones
vous voyez avec l'arrivée de même des
avec l'arrivée même des caméras des
caméras numériques et plus tard des
smartphones en fait donc le nombre de
vues a juste explosé parce que bah parce
que tout le monde a une caméra
maintenant donc tout le monde est
capable de filmer son petit Bigfoot avec
le thylacine en fait l'arrivée des
smartphones dans les années 2000 ça fait
baisser le nombre de rencontres c'est un
phénomène que je n'explique pas mais que
je trouve quand même assez fascinant
parce que normalement on devrait avoir
exactement l'opposé
voilà c'était Paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]